[Music]
[Music]
welcome to nasa's
jet propulsion laboratory in southern
california
days ago nasa's most sophisticated and
capable rover to date
landed on mars the perseverance rover
today we'll see mars like never before
with new photos and videos our panel
today will help us understand how
perseverance captured
what it's like to land on mars and what
the landing site looks like
i'm your host raquel villanueva and
joining us is matt wallace perseverance
deputy project
manager dave grull perseverance
entry descent and landing camera suite
lead
al chen perseverance entry descent and
landing lead
justin mackey perseverance imaging
scientist
and instrument operations team chief
jessica samuels perseverance surface
mission manager
ken williford perseverance deputy
project scientist
and to tell us what this all means for
nasa
and exploration thomas zurbukin
associate administrator for nasa's
science mission directorate
we will take questions during this
briefing if you're a member
of the media on the phone lines press
star one to be put in the queue
if you're on social media use the
hashtag
countdown to mars now to get us started
is
jpl director mike watkins
now i will step aside for him to give
his opening remarks
thank you welcome back to jpl we have a
jam-packed
press conference today and i was just
looking at uh at the team here i think
we're trying to add it up maybe a
hundred
years of combined experience with mars
rovers uh on the panel today
uh now we uh have been working very hard
uh since we landed
the surface team has been getting the
rover set up for the surface mission
they've been working mars time over the
weekend uh making fantastic progress
and you'll hear about that today uh
you'll also see some brand new images
and videos
that we acquired over the weekend are
downlinked over the weekend
and these are really fantastic images of
the surface of mars
uh and the rest of the descent imagery
that um
that we got a preview of uh on friday
these images have always been part of
the history of jpl
uh you know we have taken everyone along
with us on our journeys across the solar
system through the rings of saturn
looking back at the pale blue dot and
incredible panoramas on the surface of
mars
this is the first time we've been able
to actually capture
an event like the landing of a
spacecraft on mars
and these are pretty cool videos and we
will learn
something by looking at the performance
of the vehicle in these videos
but a lot of it is also to bring you
along uh on our journey
our touchdown to mars and of course uh
our surface mission as well
and uh these are really amazing videos
uh
we all binge watched them over the
weekend if you can
call a one minute video binge watching
but uh but we watched it many many times
and it's really fantastic
and uh just to show you how far we've
come in the history of jpl
i want to show one image this is from
mariner 4
in 1965. so this was actually
the first data first images sent back
from mars by mariner 4
and that was hand colored by the
engineers according to a code
like a paint by numbers uh painting
and that's there it is the first color
color image hand painted
and so when you see these videos later
uh i i think dave gruel and justin
mackey will be overjoyed that they
didn't
have to hand color each one of these uh
each one of these images
uh so my hat is off it's a great press
conference today my head is off to the
team
of you know for getting uh the rover to
where we are and these fantastic images
down
and uh to learn more about that team let
me introduce matt wallace
thanks very much mike and thanks for the
nice words about the uh
the the team i'll try to be brief
because i want to get to this video and
i know you do too
um i just want to give you a little bit
of background on how this whole thing
started
my daughter is a gymnast she's been a
gymnast since she was
a little kid and when she was about
i guess 11 years old and the project was
still in formulation
she asked me for one of those little
sports cameras
and being the indulgent parent i am i i
got her the sports camera
and she put it in the harness that it
came with
and she put the harness on and she did a
backflip
and uh i i don't know about you but
uh i cannot do a backflip
but when she showed me the video
and i watched that camera pan up to the
ceiling
and then the room go upside down
and then somehow write itself as she
landed on her feet
you know i felt for a moment
that i had a glimpse into what it would
be like if i could do a back flip
and that was the moment that inspired a
phone call to my friend
dave gruel over here
and that's what led to this system
this entry descent and landing camera
system we call them the edl
cams that you're about to see
the product of here just just in a
moment
now i don't know about you but
it is unlikely at this point my career
that i will
pilot a spacecraft down to the surface
of mars
but when you see this imagery
uh i think you will feel like you are
getting a glimpse
into what it would be like to land
successfully
in jezreel cradle crater with
perseverance
and so uh without any further delay i'm
going to turn it over to dave he'll
describe the system
and we'll get to the video thanks great
thanks matt
um the idea of adding a ruggedized
commercial
off the shelf hardware onto a flagship
spacecraft
to do a nice to have function proved to
be
quite an interesting challenge that matt
handed over to us
um along the way we encountered one uh
maybe two
people who were a little bit skeptical
of what we were trying to do
but thankfully we had the full support
of uh project leadership
um all the individuals directly
supporting the 2020
mission were super excited to help and
in the end we were able to actually
make it happen um our edl camp team
were guided by uh two two requirements
if you will
the first one was that the entry descent
and landing system
camera system must do no harm to the
flight vehicle
and that's especially important during
edl this was our one critical
requirement and as you all saw last
thursday
uh that requirement was met uh the
second item is not so much as a
requirement as it is a mantra if you
will
we get what we get and we don't get
upset
um we wanted our edl cam system to get
onto the vehicle and return amazing
imagery
of the vehicle landing in uh
jezreel crater on mars like every other
element on the mars 2020 spacecraft
individuals
worked really hard and went above and
beyond to make sure that their piece of
the spacecraft
did what it was supposed to do and would
be successful
but in the end we knew that our entry
descent and landing
camera system the mission could still be
100 successful
if our camera system didn't work and if
we could even get just one image or one
piece of information
back during edl that we shouldn't get
upset and we should be excited
so as you probably realize after last
friday's press conference
the ddo cam system successfully captured
some
amazing imagery of the vehicle's descent
and landing
on the surface of mars we collected a
little over
30 gigabytes of information
and over 23 000 images of the vehicle
uh descending down to the surface of
mars
as a quick introduction if i could have
the first graphic a reminder for some of
you uh exactly what are the sensors that
we included in the entry descent
and landing camera system uh there are
three cameras that are located on the
top of the vehicle
on the back shell those cameras actually
capture a high rate
75 frames a second imagery of the
parachute inflating in the martian
atmosphere
now one of the cameras stopped operating
coincident with the mortar fire when the
parachute was deployed and that's to be
expected
it is a very high dynamic environment
but luckily the other two cameras
continued to operate as expected and
captured some amazing
footage of the parachutes inflating in
that martian atmosphere
we put one camera on the bottom of the
descent stage
that camera looked down on the rover as
we lowered the rover on the bridles
um the mobility system latched into
position
and then the vehicle touched down onto
the surface of mars we also installed
two
cameras onto the river one top vehicle
looking up on the descent stage
so the rover could actually see the
descent stage
lower it to the surface and then ideally
fly off
the distance after it delivers
surveillance safely under the surface
then we put the camera on the bottom of
the rover
which actually looked down on the
surface of mars once the heat shield was
dropped away
and that camera continued to capture
image until the vehicle touched down on
the surface of mars
and then we also put a microphone on the
port side of
the rover now unfortunately i do have to
say that
we did not collect any audio during edl
but uh please stay tuned a little bit
later in this press conference because
we do have some exciting information
about
the edl cam microphone so now
the reaction to the edl cam videos has
been absolutely amazing
around jpl and uh we are
super excited to actually share with all
of you video imagery
of perseverance landing on the surface
of mars
please roll the video starting to
straighten up and fly
right maneuver where the spacecraft will
jettison the entry
balance masses in preparation for
parachute deploy and to roll over to
give the radar a better look at the
ground
like that indicate shoot deploy
the navigation has confirmed that the
parachute has deployed and we are seeing
significant deceleration
in the velocity our current velocity is
450 meters
per second at an altitude of about 12
kilometers from the surface
of mars heat shield set
perseverance has now slowed to subsonic
speeds and the heat shield has been
separated
this allows both the radar and the
cameras to get their first look at the
surface current velocity
is 145 meters per second at an altitude
of about
10 km nine and a half kilometers above
the surface
now filter converge velocity solution
3.3 meters per second
altitude 7.4 kilometers now has radar
lock on the ground
current velocity is about 100 meters per
second
6.6 kilometers of the surface
perseverance is continuing to descend on
the parachute we are coming
up on the initialization of terrain
relative navigation
and subsequently the priming of the
landing engines our current velocity
is about 90 meters per second at an
altitude
of 4.2 kilometers
obvious valid we have confirmation that
the lander vision system has produced a
valid solution
and part of terrain relative navigation
timing
tpa is nominal we have timing of the
landing engines
back shell set current velocity is 83
millimeters per
second at about 2.6 kilometers from the
surface of mars
we have confirmation that the back shell
has separated
we are currently performing the divert
maneuver current velocity is about 75
meters per second at an altitude
of about a kilometer off the surface of
mars
here in safety bravo we have
completed our terrain relative
navigation current speed is about
30 meters per second altitude of about
300 meters
off the surface of mars
we have started our constant velocity
accordion which means we are
conducting the sky crane about to
connect the cycling maneuver
skytrain maneuver has started
about 20 meters off the surface
we're
faithfully on the surface of mars
ready to begin taking the stands of past
life
[Applause]
it gives me goose bumps every time i i
see it just
just amazing i hope everybody kept their
uh hands
and arms inside the vehicle at all times
while i was in motion
um so i do need to say uh i wouldn't be
sitting at this podium and you wouldn't
have all seen that
uh amazing imagery uh without a a a lot
of support from an amazing team
and both those who work directly on the
edl cam task as well as also supported
us
uh across the project i thank you for
everything you've done to get us here
today uh just an amazing amazing
accomplishment so
um i'm going to turn over to al al is
going to be our color analyst
doesn't have a telestrator but he's
going to actually walk through some of
those videos in even more detail
and actually show you some just
incredible things that you can actually
see once you look at those videos over
and over
i'm not sure the color commentator is
supposed to have as many tools as i do
right now and every time i see these
videos
but i want to add my thanks to the el
camera team i mean these videos and
these images are the stuff of our dreams
it's been the what we've been dreaming
about for years so
thank you so much let's see uh
as a as dave mentioned we'll try to walk
through what we see a little bit
we won't take that much time because uh
we could spend literally all day looking
at these videos and some of us have
spent all the weekend looking at these
videos but we'll just try to show you
some highlights of
what we've been seeing and invite you
all to continue to look for more things
as we
kind of see new things every time we
look at these videos
so let's start with the parachute upload
camera and let me give you a quick
warning to
not blink because things go really fast
here
you can see that you get a sense really
of how violent that parachute deploy and
inflation are
the parachute pack it's the parachute is
packed so densely that the
pack is basically the same density as
oak and it's about 150 pounds
it gets launched out of the spacecraft
with a mortar which is basically a
cannon
with a muzzle velocity of around 100
miles an hour and the spacecraft itself
was going about a thousand miles an hour
at this point
going about 1.75 times the speed of
sound
so just in case you blink let's show you
that one more time you kind of see that
in
high speed and then or real time and
then we'll slow it down
and take a look at the details
so let's try to walk through this a bit
slower this time at about quarter speed
and we'll pause at times to point out
things we see
so let's start that rolling okay
here you can see the pack getting pushed
out of there you can kind of see the
pack right in the middle
uh as it's being pushed uh and the uh
the parachute lid which is right on top
of it it's kind of that circled to the
left of the pack
uh was on top of the pack and it was
there to protect the parachute during
entry it's got some thermal protection
system material on it
to keep the parachute nice and cool and
protected and the pack is used to push
that lid right off the vehicle
given that cannon force you can also see
some of the other things that have
popped off of that lid
which is kind of expected given how
violent this uh this launch really is so
let's move on from here
so we keep going out here you can see
the pack reach what we call line stretch
so that's as far as it's going to go
it's
where the parachute's going to start
inflating that's about 150 feet behind
the spacecraft and it got there in just
under one second so this pack is really
moving
that's pretty much as the parachute
starts to come out you can see the pack
is rotated about 90 degrees that's
pretty common
we've seen that in in some of our
testing here on earth at high altitude
as well
so let's keep going and take a look at
the inflation
science really looks textbook it's nice
and symmetric uh the parachute opens in
only about seven tenths of a second
again
really fast um there's no evidence of
tangling of the lines which is great
um that's uh there's about two miles of
lines in the parachute system
uh so the fact that we don't see any
evidence of tangling or any kind of
other misbehavior
is great news i'm sure we'll be studying
this video for many many years and
picking it apart frame by frame and of
course we have a second uh camera on
board as well
that recorded this uh this launch and
inflation of the parachute
um you might notice the pattern that's
on the uh the parachute here
the sync patterns are useful in helping
us determine the clocking or orientation
of the parachute
also the contrasting sections can be
useful in tracking different positions
of the parachute different portions of
the parachute as it inflates
um so it's especially useful when we
have multiple cameras as we do here and
they're trying to track features in the
parachute inflating
in addition to enabling incredible
science we hope our efforts in our
engineering can inspire others
sometimes we leave messages in our work
for others to find for that purpose
so we invite you all to give it a shot
and show your work
let's move on to the rover download
camera and take that a little bit more
detail
so if we start that up you can see the
heat shield falling away very nicely and
symmetrically
uh pausing here we can take a look at
what we see on the on the heat shield
first we see the medley components on
the heat shield you can see the
electronics box and the gold wires that
lead to all the various
to all the various sensors that measure
the aerodynamics and heating
during entry during the entry portion of
flight we can also see some white cuts
in different places both on the heat
shield and free flying uh which are
likely frost that accumulated on the
heat shield
that heat shield is really really cold
during cruise so it's not at all
unexpected to see some of that frost
appearing on the heat shield
on the inside you can also see something
we didn't expect to see if you kind of
look at the
four o'clock position on the heat shield
or so
towards the middle somewhere somewhere
between the middle and the edge
um one of the springs that helped push
the heat shield off seems to have come
loose
it doesn't you know it's not much of a
big deal but it's definitely uh
not what we expected if you look at the
other eight uh
springs they actually are where they're
supposed to be all around the edge of
the heat shield
there's no danger to the spacecraft here
uh but it's uh something we
we expect and i think we wouldn't see if
we didn't have the camera system to show
us what was going on
so let's keep rolling here we can see
that the heat shield basically stays in
the same orientation as it
flies away from us it'll come back into
view in a little bit but this is uh this
is great this is kind of what we
expected in terms of the aerodynamics of
that heat shield it doesn't tumble or do
something
weird that was unexpected in flight so
that's very useful to have this video to
show us that
so in interest time let's skip ahead to
about 15 seconds before backshell
separation
so starting this video here you can see
that the spacecraft is rocking back and
forth
while hanging under the parachute this
this rocket is less than it was earlier
in flight but
pretty much what we expect there that
white flash was back shell separation
and you can see us throttle up and begin
our divert maneuver you can see the
vehicle's turned over so we're actually
beginning to fly
east and that's why you can see the the
delta over there
um as it as it maneuvers eastward to the
eventual landing site it actually passes
over the field of view will pass over
the landing site and then kind of
overshoot it a little bit
because it's got to stop that horizontal
divert that we did
you can see everything's nice and smooth
now that the engines are under control
that
on-chip parachute rocking is gone
so here we are slowing down and stopping
and we're coming straight down on our
eventual landing site here
you can see that as we as we're really
going to slow down here you can see the
engines as we get lower
uh throttle up there and stop us here
and you can see it beginning to push all
that dust around on the ground
on the two sides that shaking there is
the rover deploying and the mobility
during skycrane
and uh here we are coming down and that
that uh rocking motion of the
of the rover we'll see in other videos
uh but that settles down right before we
hit the ground in a nice
safe flat spot uh there doesn't appear
to be too much of concern that's right
below us
so that was the rover's view looking
down let's take a look at the descent
stage view
looking down as well during that
skycrane portion of flight
so here we go the rover begins to drop
away from the descent stage and that's
the first
the first part of the mobility deployed
you can kind of see here right before we
pause that the
mobility kind of shook a little bit in
that in that first deployment
here you can see the uh the bridles that
are hanging down from the top of the
picture those are what's supporting the
weight of the rover below the descent
stage
and if you look down toward the left the
bottom part of the image and toward the
left
you can see that gold unbubble that's
what's transferring all the information
between the rover and the descent stage
including this video this picture is
coming down from the camera up on the
descent stage down to the rover through
that cord
in addition to other information that's
going back and forth
so as we keep going here you can see the
bogey
that's on both sides of the mobility
back you see those wheels the back two
wheels on either side swing down
that caused a little bit of rocking of
the rover as expected but you can kind
of see that kind of settles out a little
bit
uh right as we enter the that the lumen
dust cloud
as we get down and touch down and the
video ends a touchdown of course because
the camera that's taking this video
uh is about to leave this area in a
hurry on that descent stage after we uh
we cut it loose from the rover
um so now let's take a look at the rover
upload camera so now staring up at the
at the descent stage from the rover
so here we go we got a really close up
look at the scent stage and we can start
rolling that
um you can see the descent stage as the
rover begins to fall away from it
and see the effect of that rover wobble
from the mobility deploy
so pausing here the first thing that
most people will probably notice is that
there's no
no plumes or no visible smoke or
anything else coming out of the rockets
at the corner of the descent that's
expected hydrazine doesn't really
isn't a combustion uh reaction when we
when we burn it uh the exhaust products
are
nitrogen and hydrogen which are clear so
we expect the
the plumes to be clear that's what we
see in tests here on earth as well
uh so i can promise you those engines
are on though uh one thing you can see
in this
in the earth testing we do is that the
chambers the thrust chambers
of those engines get kind of hot and
glow pink and you can kind of see that
in here especially if you look at the
the the engine at the very top right of
this image if you look closely right
above the uh
the engine bell there on the truss
chamber you can see little streaks of
pink on there
and that's what's happening as the
engines have been on for a long time
they get really hot
and that heat shows up there in those
pink stripes that we see
so take a look at that closely when you
get a chance to look at the image in
some detail
as with the previous videos you can see
the bridles that are supporting the
weight of the rover there at the bottom
now of this image
and that umbilical again transferring
transferring data back and forth between
the
stage and the rover so let's keep going
a little bit more
you'll see the image begin to wobble a
little bit here i can promise not the
descent stage wobbling it's actually
that rover tipping back and forth a
little bit as we saw
as the mobility deploys both the first
initial mobility deploy
and then the the uh the bogeys uh to
flying
um i'll be near touchdown let's slow it
down a bit and uh proceed in slow mo
here
um so now we're watching about quarter
speed things are getting pretty dusty
here as we get down
down toward the bottom take a look here
at the bottom left of this picture
um you'll see actually the instant that
we cut the descent stage away
and you'll see those models begin to get
retracted up toward that descent stage
as they're pulled up and this is as
planned
see as they got yanked up there uh right
before and then we'll see the
descent stage begin to turn and ascend
and head out uh toward the northwest
with the
umbilical dangling behind it um
since the rover was pointed almost
directly to the southeast the descent
stage chose to
go toward the back that's also to make
sure of course that the uh
the engines don't plume the rover that
we don't damage the rover
uh with those uh that engine thrust so
we sent that descent stage
off to the northwest which uh jessica
will show you about in a little bit
um so i can and have watched those
videos for hours and keep seeing new
stuff every time
um so i invite you all to do that too um
so now i'll turn it over to justin who
will talk to you a little bit about the
images we've been taking on the ground
all right thank you al uh i'm justin
mackey uh
i'm the mars 2020 perseverance uh
imaging scientist here uh and i
developed imaging systems at jpl
and uh when when dave asked me to help
out with the edl cam development about
uh six years ago uh we were
i was really excited about it it would
be challenging and interesting
um and even possibly spectacular but i
had no idea that it would be this
amazing and we are so
happy and proud and i just want to thank
dave and
matt for just giving us the leadership
and
giving us a chance to do this um like
matt and dave and jennifer and rick
and others on the project i've i've
actually worked on all five of the nasa
revolutions and as
part of my job i review images from mars
like every day that's what i do
and when i saw these images come down um
i have to say
i was truly amazed i know it's been a
tough year
for everybody and we're hoping that
maybe these images will you know help
brighten people's day
um you know your smartphones and
make them your your screen backgrounds
and things i'm just really
happy that it all so uh so now we're on
mars
and um i'm going to talk a little bit
about what we've been doing over the
weekend
um over the weekend we deployed the rsm
if you go to the first picture there's a
picture of the remote sensing mask the
rsm
which is that mast on the rover and you
can see the um the navigation cameras up
there the left and right navigation
cameras or nav cams as we call them
um this is another new imaging system
that we've
uh developed here specifically for the
2020 mission
these cameras represent a pretty
significant advancement over previous
imaging systems that we've flown
these are 20 megapixel color cameras
with very high resolution and wide angle
lenses
that we use to basically map out the
surface as the river drives and then we
use these images to do planning and
things
and so we um the first thing we did
after we deployed the masses we started
imaging the surface so the next slide
shows one of our first images from the
cameras
this image is actually in low resolution
mode
so it's one quarter of the full
resolution of the of the camera so it's
been it's been shrunk down
uh but you can see right there the vista
that we're seeing this is uh the rover
obviously on mars and you can see some
of the material that landed on the deck
but everything looks in good shape and
so we're using these images to inspect
not only the vehicle but the surface
around us the next slide
was the view down towards the surface
you can see the wheels there
this is the same surface you just saw in
the edl cam videos
you could see some of the scouring that
the rocket plumes did for us
clean it off make it nice and clean so
we can take pictures of it and dust it
off for us
the next slide shows a view looking out
towards the south and it's just an
amazing scene here uh this is it this is
mars where
we're here in our place that we're going
to be exploring over the next months and
coming years
and it's just really exciting to see um
you know these scenes look familiar
to us you know they look earth-like in a
sense you know you see the
mountains back there and the rocks and
things it just
really is the surface of an alien world
and we just arrived
you can also see some more scouring
there over on the right
the next image looks over towards the
west you can see the delta
out there on the horizon and again more
scouring from the
uh the rocket plumes and then we take
all of these images
and we uh stitch them together into
panoramas and so that next
the next frame shows the full panorama
from the nav cam
uh stitched together we're still working
out the calibration of things so this is
uh you know
approximate color but it just gives you
a feel for
the vista here that we were our new
environment that we're going to explore
uh and we're hoping uh everyone will
join us uh
in um seeing these images where uh
today we're gonna be releasing a whole
slew of raw images um it's been a fire
hose of data basically we have thousands
of images already from the edl cameras
nav cams you've seen in haz camps and so
we will be putting those uh out on the
website today uh for people to download
and
process yourself or just look at the
great picture find your favorite picture
and uh make it make your screen
background and and then the last um
image that i just wanted to point out is
the um first image one of the first
images from the mastcam
z camera this is another next generation
imaging system on the rover
um jim bell is the dep the pi i'm the
deputy pi for this
uh working with our industry partners ms
cubed
down in san diego um this is just a
fantastic imaging system this is a
preview of things to come
this system has a zoom lens on it that's
what the z stands for
uh and we're going to get incredibly
high resolution photos
from this imaging system i just wanted
to point out a few things in this
picture
on the far right you could see those
cables
where they had been cut uh in video that
you just saw so there's kind of a
close-up of that
uh and then just in the middle to the
left of that that black
uh instrument that's uh the rover upload
camera that's the camera that actually
took the video of the sky crane
as as we were coming down and then in
the bottom of the frame is the mass cam
z calibration target
set there's two of them there's the
circular one with the the shadow post
and then the color
chips on the bottom there's another cal
target in the back that's the super cam
instrument
with our partners from los alamos and in
france uh we're going to be
commissioning supercam over the next few
days
and then finally just as a teaser i'll
point out that there is a little antenna
there to the right on that
uh box in the center right that is the
helicopter antenna it's a helicopter
base station location
and a preview of things to come we're
excited about that as well
so with that i'm going to turn it over
to jessica to talk about latest status
all right thank you justin i know you
can test first
hand to being in the control room and
the excitement that
everybody has been experiencing seeing
all these images from the surface
and uh as they come down you know we're
immediately
sharing them and everybody clapping and
smiles all around
great camera suite so i am happy to
report
that perseverance is healthy and
uh continuing with activities as we have
been
uh planning them um over the first few
sols on the surface
to date which is really only just you
know three solves activities and one
more
um and coming up later this afternoon uh
we've commanded
five thou we've executed 5000 commands
so lots of uh instructions to the
vehicle for
her to perform and uh having everything
come back exactly how we've been wanting
it to
um with respect to our health checkouts
and our instrument
at checkout so that's been things have
been going well a couple of
key highlights so we have fired and
replete and released um our launch lock
restraints to allow our mechanisms uh to
be deployed
we saw the remote sensing mast but
one of those also being the high gain
antenna now this is
um important for the high gain antenna
to be deployed because
it increases our uplink rate um to the
rover and so it will
allow us to send a higher
volume of instructions to perseverance
and allow her to perform
more involved activities over the days
to come
additionally with respect to our
communication
we have established a strong
communication link
with all of our relay orbiters and our
partners
um the mars reconnaissance orbiter the
maven
orbiter trace gas observer the tgo
and odyssey spacecraft and so we thank
those teams and are happy to be able to
use those assets
to relay all of the information that we
all these beautiful images that we are
looking
at today the remote sensing mash
remote sensing masked motion checks
were normal and as expected and
all of our instruments have gone through
their initial checkouts
and we're happy to report that they are
all performing
um nominally as expected now when i say
nominal that really means
fantastic because of we can't
wait to continue to use this
just for the surface mission as part of
this flight software load it will take
us a few days
to transition but once we're on that
load it will allow us to do further
in-depth checkouts of the instrument
as well as deploy the robotic arm
and exercise some of the turret
items that you see in this image so you
can see that we have our coring drill in
the center
our pixel and sherlock instruments
mounted to the side
and that black tank is to support the
gut the
gas dust removal tool which will uh
remove uh dust from the surfaces that we
will be inspecting later
so uh coming up here the uh the wheels
uh if you noticed in the image now or
off to the side we will be performing a
wiggle
we'll straighten those up we'll do a
short drive
and as i mentioned deploy the robotic
arm
and then continue with further in-depth
checkouts
so we are very excited to be happily on
the surface
and uh and exercising our system
and looking for what's ahead
so going back to our partnership with
the larger mars
spacecraft and science teams and
community we're really excited
that the mro spacecraft mars
reconnaissance orbiter
and the highrise team was able
to find our hardware on the surface of
mars so if you see in this image
if the next pop-up you can see that we
have the descent stage
the parachute and the heat shield all
here um in this image with a few
stats here the descent stage is about
700 meters
away from where perseverance is on the
surface
parachute is about 1.2 kilometers and
the heat shield about 1.5 kilometers
and so it's a very exciting that we can
see all these
different components now that we've
landed on the surface
and as a special treat the high-rise
image was able to actually acquire
the entry descent landing event from
their perspective
and uh we can never have enough images
of this activity and so this is a
fantastic view
but i'm going to send it back to dave
here he
is part of this suite we have one more
surprise or one more
gift i'll say um that that we've been
able to
receive from this package over here dave
thanks jessica so i think we probably
have overloaded your visual sense for a
little bit but we're going to do
something a little bit different and
i'm going to have some fun here for a
second too so i'm going to get rid of
this
and i'm going to talk to you now with
this this is the microphone
that was part of the edl camera system
um when the edl cam system was first
envisioned it was set up as
just a bunch of cameras to capture some
amazing imagery on the surface of mars
and about a year or so after it was
first conceived i got a phone call
another call from matt after talking to
headquarters asked the question
could we possibly put a microphone as
part of our edl camera
system so we work with the team we took
a look
and uh sure enough it was something that
we could do and so we started off that
detail design
and uh identifying a microphone that
would work for us and uh getting it onto
the vehicle about a year after
uh this first started i'm giving a tour
at jpl and i happened to mention to the
group that i was giving the tour to
that the decision had come down we're
working to actually include a microphone
onto
onto the vehicle and after the tour was
done a gal came
up to me and she said some things to me
that i won't forget anytime soon
she said i'm super excited that you guys
are going to try to put a microphone
onto the rover and get it to the surface
of mars and i was very appreciative and
i asked her afterwards i said
i'm curious why is it that this relates
to you so much
and her response was that her sister was
visually impaired
she was not able to see these images
that uh
that we saw earlier or that we've sent
down in the past
and while she tries to describe them to
her she felt that she just
can't quite capture that same sense of
amazement that she gets when she gets
individually
and that by actually getting a
microphone at the surface of mars
the hope was that she'd be able to
experience things on mars
the same way that uh that she was when
she actually looked at them
and that stuck with me we continued to
work super hard to make sure that this
microphone would work
and that's part of the reason we were
disappointed why it didn't work when we
actually went and did
our entry descent learning sequence um i
wish i had actually captured
that individual's name i would love to
reach out to her now and say
we've done it i hope your sister is
enjoying it
because what i'm going to show you in a
second or what i'm going to you're going
to hear in a second is actually the
first sounds being recorded from
the surface of mars so there are two
microphones on the perseverance vehicle
there's this microphone here part of the
entry descent and landing system and
there's a second microphone that is on
the supercam instrument
and we're we're counting on both these
instruments recording some
absolutely amazing uh sounds from
the surface of mars so with that um i
invite you now to if you would like to
close your eyes and just imagine
yourself sitting
on the surface of mars and listening to
to the surroundings
if i could have the first one please
so that gentle whirl that happens in the
background that is a noise made by the
rover
but yes what you did here 10 seconds in
was an actual wind gust on the surface
of mars
picked up by the microphone sent back to
us here on earth
you know this indicates that was around
a five meter per second type of wind
gust
um so we've actually we sit here now and
actually tell you that we have recorded
sound
from the surface of mars so we have a
second one
which basically further reduces the
noise of the rover
so you can just hear uh what the wind
would sound like on mars and once again
i invite you to to sit back and uh have
a listen to what it would sound like to
be on mars
[Music]
that's just it's cool it's really neat
overwhelming
if you will um i can't remember what i
was going to go and say next
um so looking forward to doing some
amazing things with the microphones
going forward we need to work with the
ops team there's some great science that
they're looking to do we're hopeful that
we continue to use these microphones
both the super cam microphone and the
edl cam microphone
to capture sounds perhaps the rocks
interacting with the surface
supercam is going to use theirs to get
some great data of
them zapping rocks so as you've heard
and we'll continue here we're just
beginning to do amazing things on the
surface of mars
and now ken is going to talk to you a
little bit about the science that we've
done to date and what they're looking
forward to doing as we continue to move
forward
thanks dave and i'll start by just
taking this opportunity to say to matt
dave al and everybody else on this
fantastic team
thank you for the ride of a lifetime
that
is just incredible what we've seen today
and and what i'm sure
we'll continue to see as the mission
unfolds
so with all the focus on these uh
spectacular videos and
audio uh we wanted to make sure to
remind you that there is plenty of
science going on
already with hundreds of team members
poring over every new
image so if we can get the first of
those
uh images as you'll see in this
navcam frame we start with what may seem
like
very basic observations light rocks dark
rocks holy rocks that's holy with an e
we use these very generic terms at this
early stage
until we have more data that allow us to
test our hypotheses
and make more confident interpretations
follow along with the mission and you'll
see the
theme as we get closer our view of mars
continues to resolve
and a coherent story emerges
next image please
i just want to briefly point out that we
are finding real science value in these
edl cam videos
here you can see a beautiful new
perspective on the jezero delta
and if we can get the next image
also a new perspective on some of the
beautiful stratigraphy around our
landing site which is
is up near uh on the far right side of
this image
uh so now to put all of this in context
for us i'll hand it over to dr thomas
well what we've seen here today is
really nothing
short of amazing you know and i perhaps
you've had moments like this before
some of you have told me that i was
too young to remember but they had a
moment like that for example when they
observed
the first landing on the moon they had
moments like that where it felt
that we took a big leap a big leap not
just
in this case because of at jpl or at
nasa but a big louis
as humanity uh of course it's a leap
that was enabled by work over decades
and on this mission for close to a
decade
so what's possible today or feels
possible is different
even and yesterday it's how it
feels to make history and i just that's
how i feel today i'm so moved by this
wow
the video of perseverance is sand and
landing and the amazing panorama and the
first
white landscape shot of chess rock scene
with human eyes and the first martian
sounds
are the closest you can get to landing
on parts without putting on a pressure
suit
that video i believe should become
mandatory view
for young people who not only want to
explore other worlds
and build spacecraft to take them there
but also want to be part of diverse
teams achieving all the occasional
schools of our future
at the center of that is a team and i'll
ask for the next image
now you should know i met this team i
see me there in a dark suit uh next to
uh dr laurie glaze the planet division
director and now
he just uh he just talked to you is on
his knee in there and
he entered ascendant landing team and we
met him just hours before that historic
landing
and i love this picture because of
course
the event today demonstrates that the
human aspect of exploration
and that is of course every reason for
what we can do
at nasa and also why we do things
the audio images here are
provided to us are from the surface
of mars and sometimes we forget if we
look at that
well i hope i shouldn't get all the fun
uh we want to make sure that all of us
on earth
see and feel what it's like to be on our
mars and explore other worlds
i'm so excited for more than one million
students who join
our student challenge and that many more
across the world will be inspired by
these
images released today and even yesterday
their journey is also just the beginning
just imagine
imagine perseverance sitting on a hill
recording the next martian landing
with a cargo that is basically a rocket
and then the first
from another world with samples bound
for earth that are collected by
perseverance now in the near future
imagine follow the entry descendant of
the first human crew on the planetary
surface sometimes
in the future this future historical way
which i'm confident will happen will be
enabled
by women and men working in diverse
teams
imagine the goals we can achieve
together so what is possible
sometimes to address that question it's
good to look back and think where we've
come from just like my friend mike did
earlier
we've been on a journey both as a human
race for
for quite a while now and i don't want
to show this next image of
sojourner of the pathfinder mission
uh which was designed for seven souls or
martian
days or so maybe 30. ultimately lasted
for 85
earth days in 1997. i
remember that really this thing clear
through pathfinder instead
in indeed that you know weighed 23
pounds and i
returned a surprising amount of data
back to earth and i'm trying a
surprising amount of science for many
scientists i must say
some people didn't expect quite that
much and that's what happened sometimes
too
when you went on my bait just like we've
seen here
we've grown from that seat that
perseverance is the size of a small car
and it's ready
for us for the next shine leaves and
here's a picture
that we're putting up that is one of the
many pictures that i were releasing
and of course it's a picture one of my
absolute favorite
and that's a picture of the sample
caching system on there because it's
that sample caching system that will
connect this mission
to the samples that will bring back to
earth
and other historic feed we're working on
this system is on the surface of most
now i remember this
looking at it before we packed it up
from jpl and moved it over
then of course uh launched it from
from the top of a rocket that's my
friends
it's one of the indelible moments in
assets history
where what we can see and what we can
learn and what we can hope for the
future and the extraordinary emotions
that takes
makes us feel all of us coming together
that human element will put our future
at mars which is bright indeed
and it will fuel the dreams of a new
generation
that will return to mars and also study
the samples
that we will eventually bring home i'm
so grateful
to this team and literally that
thousands both at jbl and within the us
and around the world
all of you who have engaged in this
mission
as has been noted the raw image pipeline
is opening up please go take a look at
these data and play with them especially
those of you
uh the children and the youth that have
signed up to our educational campaign
what can you find in these pictures and
who's going to compose the first piece
of music with actual mars
sound mike matt jennifer al
many of you leaders and could not be
more proud
of both you and your team on behalf of
our entire nasa leadership team
a heartfelt and a proud thanks to you
for the record matt i'm so glad for your
idea
about these cameras we will learn a lot
from that
much more than we ever expected and of
course this is just
a start for the surface team a real work
starts now
to evaluate the surrounding and start a
plan and our trajectory across chesro
crater
it's a big team and there are lots of
discussions
at that science in action
stay with us there is much more
amazement to come back to you raquel
thank you thomas and we'll now move on
to your questions
remember if you are a member of the
media on the phone line you can press
star one to get
into the queue if you're on social media
you can tag questions
with the hashtag countdown to mars now
starting on the phone line is
bill harwood from cbs news
yeah hi um i guess it's the pharrell or
maybe for matt
i mean other than the the loose spring
you guys saw on the heat shield is there
anything at
all in that video that looked all
phenomenal i mean
you know it looked like it was almost
textbook um
and i'm not saying that just to i don't
know
give you free praise but i didn't see
you know i don't see anything like that
so
is there anything thanks we've been i
can take that when uh
we've been pouring over those videos and
looking for anything that uh that could
be wrong and also looking at the rest of
the data
and we did have a pretty clean run uh
through through entry descent and
landing
uh there are a couple bits of the uh
pair of the parachute lid uh that came
off
um some of that was expected in fact we
knew that there was some risk
of that as well um and there was if you
look at the video you can actually see a
chunk
uh that's the uh the radome it's a uh a
cover
uh for one of the uh one of the login
antennas we use during cruise and also
during part of edl
uh that came off uh we had hoped that it
wouldn't and we tried to restrain it a
little bit better but we knew that it
was a risk that it might
so that's something we noticed uh that's
on there as well there's a couple other
little things that we've been taking a
look at
uh but i think you're in general right
that the the extra descent and landing
system behaves as expected
and it did what it had to do um
especially given uh
and a big shout out to the terrain
melton navigation system which put us
down
in the safest spot that was available to
us the places that we had to choose from
um weren't great if we didn't have
something like three and ulta navigation
so yeah the landing system worked great
great thanks al and up next we have
marcia dunn from the associated press
yes hi um wonderful video i'm just
wondering did the jpl team
get to see snippets coming down in the
video um
and then or did you have to wait until
this one-minute
video was put together what was the
reaction when you
saw it first saw the video and laid eyes
on it and and
for david um why do you think mike
didn't work during
defense thank you
i could say a couple words about the
first part
um i had trouble leaving this mission
support area
this week just because i kept waiting
for every little bit of information to
come back from uh particularly from
these cameras but from the vehicle in
general
and i can tell you every time we got
something people were
overjoyed giddy they were like kids
you know in a candy store uh you know we
get a little
we get a thumbnail which literally is
just a really low res
bloody looking thing of of one of those
videos
that came down first and we'd just be
falling on the floor
excited with what we were seeing and
that's before even the high res came
you know um there's a lot of people
that have contributed to uh to this
entry descent and landing system
are our chief engineer adam stelzner
happens to be here
in the uh the studio he was kind of the
father
of the sky crane system this started 15
years ago for him
he and his team have never seen this
system operate before not even on the
earth because we can't test it on the
earth
so this is the first time we've had a
chance as engineers to actually see what
we designed
and uh i just can't it's hard for me to
express just how emotional it was and
how exciting it was for everybody
as we got this information down i'll
turn it over to dave to say a couple
words
before you said that can i just chime in
on the the first image of this justin
i will say when when we get these first
image
any of these imaging systems the test
images never look as good as the real
thing it's not even close
in fact it's very hard to simulate a lot
of these things especially these
you know sky cranes and things and so
the images that we normally see during
test programs are
um you know there's always like a ladder
in the background
or the lighting's never quite right or
there's a car in the case of the edl
camera these big targets out in parking
lots and
we were dodging cars to try to do our
tests and things and so
that moment that you get these images
from mars it's it's just kind of an
electric
feeling where it just all just snaps
into place and you get these pictures
that are just like
perfectly you know they're pictures of
mars that you can never simulate here on
earth
and i think that we all experience that
especially after you we go through
months and months of testing
and the images don't really look that
great and you know people get skeptical
like are these these cameras really that
great because
you know that looks like a garage or
something uh so
we're it's just amazing to get these
pictures and i just i think we all feel
that way because we're all
seeing pictures of insides of labs and
everything and they're never that great
that
uh it's amazing to get these photos from
ours okay i'll give you my take so uh
thursday evening and friday when the uh
data started to come down
and uh kind of realized what we had i
was sitting at home
and my phone started to go off and i was
getting face times from people who were
in the msa and what was happening was
that they were starting to show them on
the monitors that we have hanging on the
wall
and people were turning their phones
around and saying girl you got to see
this reaction and people were just
jumping up and down and giddy and
ecstatic and it
it was a great feeling i mean from where
i was sitting i only was excited to see
these videos that we had captured
it was also the fact that a lot of
people had put a lot of effort in to
make this system
work and to actually reward that effort
and to
to pay it back and and get this
excitement going
it made me super happy i was glad to see
that all the hard work all the
dedication had come in and that everyone
was just
excited about uh not only what we
captured but
also what this mission um could do going
for forwards
it was a great feeling it was a feeling
i won't i won't forget for for quite
some time
and then regarding the question about
the microphone we started to look at it
what we think happened is that there was
a communication error
between uh the device that is
responsible for
uh digitizing the analog signal that the
microphone picks up and then passing
that
to the uh the computer that actually
stores all the data
we're not exactly sure why it has been a
fact it was just so much data
in the system we tested it but you know
obviously
everything's a little bit different on
mars than we actually have here here on
the ground so
we were pretty quickly able to determine
didn't think there was a hardware issue
with the microphone which is why we were
able to uh approach the product
and get their concurrence to try to turn
the microphone on then on that salt
ii boundary it's just unfortunate that
that air happened during the edl
and we just weren't able to record any
of the data that uh that we generated
during the sequence all right
thanks and up next we have chris
davenport from the washington post
hi uh thanks for taking the time and for
showing us i really appreciate it um
i wonder if you could talk a little bit
about the cameras that were used to
record the video
i understand they were specially
designed maybe a commercial company
called
fl ir systems just curious to know
like what goes into you know designing a
camera to sustain the the g's
the blast of the thrusters everything
that it's got to go through to capture
that
images uh thanks okay so
the cameras were originally purchased
from a company called
point grey which was then bought out by
flir
um and i can tell you that the
modifications we made to the camera were
minimal this was not a camera
specifically designed for use on mars
you can purchase the same camera off the
internet for whatever applications you
might have for it
the only things we did is we actually uh
added some bonding material on the
inside
to try to make sure that in the dynamic
environment of launch
and then that mortar fire event that
they talked about uh that the camera
would continue to operate
and then we had to swap out a couple
pieces on the inside because
in the vacuum of space they had the
ability to outgas
material and if that material deposited
itself on the detector then we can get
this clear images that we actually got
but other than that
it was not specially designed for use
for this application it's a commercial
off the shelf camera
thank you and up next we have michael
sheets
from cnc
hi congratulations again on capturing uh
stunning footage
of this landing i'm curious on two
aspects i mean
one at adam seltzer you know you guys
had said that
in 15 years since he really engineered
the sky crane you've never actually seen
an operation
i'm curious what adam thinks about
seeing this
work on a planet and secondarily
how this informs and how it's being able
to actually see the landing
and forms future missions even as
nasa looks to one day land astronauts
you know what does this really teach you
about trying to get people on the
surface of mars
uh well let's see adam's not up here but
i can uh i can channel him for for just
a moment perhaps and
and tell you that uh you know this is a
thrill of a lifetime
i think not just for adam but all the
people that uh contributed
uh to to this architecture development
uh back on curiosity i remember
when we first briefed this uh
this this system you know with the
supersonic parachutes and uh
you know multi-body systems and we're
going to lower this thing on a tether
and people
just looked at us like we were insane
you know
and uh adam uh and his team
of which al was part you know they kept
at it and they explained why it made
sense they explained why it was robust
they explained why it would work it was
not easy to build i will tell you that
uh as as the flight system manager on
curiosity but
once you build it and once you test it
it's something uh that really
is designed inherently to interact with
the uncertainties that
throw at you throws at you and uh
and so i think uh being able to see his
system
uh operate like this um you know
in high definition uh landing at jezreel
uh you know it doesn't get too much
better than that i don't think
so um i'm going to throw it to al you
can maybe say a few words about the
types of technologies and
and information that we have on the
technologies on the system and
information we got getting back from
edl and we'll be getting
interaction the interaction between
those rockets
and what they're doing to the ground and
how they kick things around and we've
got great video of that here this time
both from the rover download camera and
the descent stage down the cam you can
see how those uh
how they create those scours and stuff
gets pushed together and creates a sheet
underneath the rover
we can see that all occurring so that's
super useful
uh the parachute stuff too one thing we
didn't show uh necessarily here is that
that
the parachute upload cameras the two
that we got are at 75 frames per second
so we can see the inflation that only
occurs in you know 0.7 seconds in less
than a second
and see that snap open and look at all
the details of how it unfolds and
and how it's symmetrically inflated and
all those things are very useful for
future missions uh both whether they're
landing more things in people
or stuff and then people you know as
other missions are going to use future
missions like the sample retrieval
missions
are likely going to use things like
parachutes and rockets of course
uh so we're very interested in seeing
how uh how those
those cameras and what we see in the in
that in those camera images can teach us
about how those systems are actually
performing
and make our systems more robust in the
future
thanks alan matt up next we have ken
chang from the new york times
hi thank you um i wanted to give me a
few more details about
how the data came back there's 30
gigabytes that was collected
how much has come back and what was the
data rate that you were able to send the
information back
thank you maybe jessica can so i can say
that
as part of our commission activity we
actually walk
the data rate up uh over the course of
our different overflights with the
orbiters
and uh so we start um with
uh two very a lower rate um
2000 8000 and then we mo we increase
that into an adaptive data rate with the
orbiter
in which we can continue to go many
uh megabits um i'm sorry two meg
meg and then much further beyond that
um over the course uh the total volume
that i don't have off the top of my head
and so maybe
i don't know if that's something that
dave or we can provide for you later
justin do you have how many
how many images we got back yeah we got
it so uh we counted uh
yesterday that we're releasing today
there's about 4500 that we've gotten so
far that we're pushing out to the web
today
um and i will mention that when the
orbiters fly overhead
the compasses typically return let's say
500 to 900 megabits
per pass and we've had i don't know
we've had a lot of them now like five or
ten of them we typically have
two to three over flights per night and
it does vary the rates i was remember
are the communication rates from the
rover to the orbiter
and then once that's collected then
we're anywhere from
you know some passes smaller 80 uh to
100 and where we've had other passes
uh which have been significant amounts
of data
up at 700 and so it is variable per
orbiter
and per orientation yeah and i would add
one more thing i wanted to mention about
the the camera technology and then this
data um
we haven't mentioned it but in addition
to use commercial cameras um we're using
a commercial computer an
intel based pc that's running linux
open source so it's the first open
source at least that i know of open
source linux box running on the surface
of mars especially inside the rover it's
quite compact uh and so there's the
linux operating system
and we compress the video using ffmpeg
which is another open source tool so
thank you to the open source community
for allowing us to use your amazing
software
appreciate it i just uh just
very briefly i just want to note as
jessica said
you saw some of the terrific imagery
from the mars reconnaissance orbiter
we've been getting fantastic support
from the orbiter community
not just mro uh for for both that
imagery and the comms
uh but also uh from maven which is a
goddard space
spacecraft from odyssey one of our older
orbiters
uh if the esa european uh trace gas
orbiter as well some of the biggest data
volume passes we've had
brought back a lot of this imagery came
from our partners in europe and so thank
you all to them
okay and up next on the phone lines is
mike wahl
from space.com
thank you all for doing this and yeah
yeah it's really amazing video thanks
for sharing it um
just yeah there's a question for for
dave um
what do you anticipate doing maybe with
with the edl mic now that it's up and
running
do you see it having any kind of
diagnostic uses during the deployments
of the robotic arm and sort of like like
the instrument checkouts and so forth
um yeah i mean what do you see it doing
aside from recording martian wind and
the sound of the dirt under the wheels
and so on
thank you yes we've had a lot of
discussion about how we might be able to
use
both the edl cam microphone and the
supercam microphone to do those type of
diagnostic stuff i mean
the ops team right now i don't want
spooky jessica but they're focused on
getting the system deployed and
capturing
noise of that is definitely not the
first priority they need to focus on
getting this vehicle ready to perform
some amazing science
but that doesn't mean in the future we
could not sit down and discuss the
possibility of capturing
audio files of an actuator as it
actually
spins on the surface of mars um you know
the noise is an incredible thing that
engineers can use to basically
detect the health of moving systems
gears and actuators and things like that
so
if we get a snapshot of uh actuator
today
and uh you know you can compare over
time do another snapshot another audio
file of that uh
of that actuator in the future compare
the two and see if there's anything that
can be learned in terms of the health of
that uh that device
now with that said i do need to remind
everybody that uh
the the microphone that's in the edl
camera system just like all of the the
cameras and other hardware
is off the shelf hardware it is not
designed to
live in the hostile environment of mars
it gets down
120 degrees plus below zero at night and
then it warms up significantly more in
the day to
what minus 40 or something like that so
those temperature cycles and that cold
temperature are going to
[Music]
significantly limit the life of of these
devices they're just not designed to
last for long periods of time the
supercam microphone might continue to
work it actually is designed a little
bit more
for this particular environment it can
last longer so i think
you know as you heard i think dr z
mentioned earlier we're always surprised
by
how rugged and robust some of our items
are how long they actually last
you know they they continue to operate
far longer than we designed them
we've gotten pretty lucky over the last
couple of days perhaps we'll get lucky
and the hardware will continue to
operate
uh on the surface of mars and allow us
to do those type of diagnostic things in
the future
i don't just you want anything more
about how you might consider using them
uh
well i can i can say that that
application was one of the things that
we had projected
and tested and wanted to make sure that
even though this was
a capability that was part of the cruise
and entry descent landing software
package that we're operating right now
we've also carried that capability
forward into our surface software
and so um assuming the hardware is good
we uh
we're open and ready to use it yeah and
i will mention
um to the question we we actually have
gotten requests from instrument teams
wanting to turn on the microphone to
observe their instrument functioning
moxie is one of the instruments that's
going to be generating oxygen has
compressors and scroll pumps and things
and they actually want to want us to use
the microphones to do diagnostic
acoustic measurements so i
actually think that this might become
something that all rovers might want
because
everybody knows that when you hear
something squeaking it's diagnostic
maybe you need to
check it out and it tells you a little
bit about how it works
and so we will find out how these get
used it's actually kind of exciting
um and we're getting rest from the teams
so we're gonna and we're working to put
those into the plan
i'll just say i hope it does survive
long enough
so that we can hear those wheels crunch
over the surface of the planet because i
think we would hear it
and i think it'd be great to hear that
big rotary percussive
jackhammer drill taking that first
sample
of a rock on on mars as well i think
we'd hear that also
so i'm hopeful that that our our little
microphone will hang in there for
for some of those events
okay and up next is lisa grossman from
science news
hi thanks for taking my question um the
video is amazing and a lot of it looks a
lot like the
um animations that you've shown before
the landing to kind of advertise this
excuse me going forward how will you
distinguish the video
that is the real video from the
animations to kind of make it
clear to people what they're looking at
and keep them from getting confused or
not be fueled for conspiracy theorists
thing we haven't actually done this
i guess i could try to take that one i
mean i think we should label very
clearly which ones
are from mars and uh and not uh i think
it's
cleared a lot of us but i think you're
right right given the way that the
animation has been pretty good
uh you getting a i get a sense for uh
for how that could be confusing i think
we should label them going forward now
that we have this kind of you know
we should be clear about what's uh
what's real
what a great problem to have exactly i
mean it's an amazing problem
[Laughter]
justin do you have anything uh anything
any thoughts
yeah i i can't attest to it's real
it's actually real i know because i know
the data very well it's
it's stunning and it's real and that was
our thought too when we first saw it
we're like wow this
looks like doesn't look real um but it
is
and that's what's so amazing about it
and um
you know i i know i've seen some of the
videos are getting pretty good you know
second class you look at a sports game
and it looks like it's real but it's
fake but this
is actually real stuff and that's why
it's so exciting
um and i actually just want to say uh
for those of you that
watch the videos personally i like
watching like quarter
quarter speed or even slower because
there's so much detail in there
that anyone who's done animations know
that knows that
that would take a lot of time to do uh
and it all happened so quickly and the
camera cut everything and so that's how
that's how we know it's real because we
we know so much about these these
systems but
there's just so much detail um that
that's
that's one way that you could you could
look at um but yeah
there's one thing i forgot too i
remember early on msl when we started
coming up with the animation for uh
for curiosity's landing uh we had a
discussion about the uh the plumes
actually coming out of this dense stage
uh and the fact that uh that they were
clear and that you wouldn't see them
uh in real life like you you don't see
them in the rover upload camera
um but uh we thought that it would be uh
that people would be expecting to see
them in the
in the animation so they took some
artistic license and putting them there
so here i can tell you now that
hopefully our future animations will uh
will show the right thing and show the
the clear plumes like you see in the
real video
the same comment for the exquisite
detail on the rover if you actually look
at you know every
target's in place every little twist you
know every tie cable tie they're all
there
in the animations you don't have that
when you get down to that level of
detail
at least at least now you typically
don't because a lot of the things happen
kind of last minute and you know the
rover's getting built and people slap
things on and they're not in the drawing
so the animators don't pick it up
uh and that's another thing that's
amazing about this video every single
detail is in there so
encourage people to look at it it's fun
thanks justin it really is some
beautiful detail now we have a social
media question to take
jerome on twitter asks some pictures we
can see dirt and small
rocks inside the real wheel rim
was this expected and will it become an
issue if more dust and sand is picked up
along the way
yep i can i can speak to that so uh it's
not
uncommon for us to have uh rocks and
dirt inside the wheels um
at either from the landing event or as
we're driving
across the surface you'll also notice on
the deck
we also experienced some of that debris
coming down on top of the rover and we
design our mechanisms for these
conditions
so we don't expect any issue with the
material from the landing event or as we
continue to surf
rove across the surface
thanks jessica and right now we have a
call from
eric berger on ars technica
yes hi thank you very much for doing
this congratulations on such a stunning
array of photos and videos um alan
chen or al chen mentioned the dust
earlier and i
it was striking as the spacecraft got
close to the surface how much was kicked
up
um it's a one-ton rover it's pretty
sizable but you know when you're talking
about human missions
um it's it's much larger and so you know
what does
you know what does being able to see
this dust tell us about the challenge of
landing future
kind of much larger spacecraft on mars
is that something
that you're going to have to account for
and if you know
is it going to be a really significant
issue to deal with thank you
yeah i think i take that one i mean i
think you know as most people know right
there
as far as i'm aware there are no landing
pads on on mars or barges that we can
land on
uh prepared places so we we're gonna
have to deal with especially for news
repulsion where we have to deal with
uh this plume ground interaction and
it's really difficult it's difficult to
get right
uh to get the modeling right to get uh
to understand it or even to do a real
test that does that shows a good
impression of what you're going to come
down on
especially when you don't know exactly
where you're going and what the terrain
is like
and what the ground properties are where
you're coming down so i do think this is
a big challenge
for us going forward and that's why
collecting this information here is
useful
we can certainly begin to see how it
actually behaved in real life and see
how things
began to move and what those scours are
like and we have a vehicle that will
tell us what the ground that we happen
to land on was like
and we know how we were commanding those
uh those engines and where they were
pointed
so we have a rich treasure trove here
that we can use to kind of
get at that kind of challenge uh but
because i do think it's a big one
especially as we start to land heavier
and heavier things
uh with bigger and bigger engines
and up next on the phone lines is joey
roulette from
the verge hey uh thanks for
doing this earlier it was mentioned that
scientists are
already pouring through the thousands
and thousands of images and
i was just wondering what about um the
surface of the rocks that you guys have
seen so far from these images
are standing out uh and kind of what has
been
interesting from a scientific
perspective thanks
ken uh some ken's there yeah okay ken
sure uh so uh you can go online and
see that image uh that was put up uh
during my
little bit there but um we're noticing
basically the different
colors that we see and and textures and
tones and
and so one thing that's striking to me
standing out to me
some of us is that um a lot of the the
rocks that are labeled as
light rocks uh seem to have a rough
texture
uh whereas some of the darker rocks
further afield that that are
higher standing um more like large
boulders
um seem to be smoother um
that can mean something about the the
grain size and the
and the potentially the composition uh
of the rocks themselves
one of the things where we're noting um
as the resolution gets better
is that these these light rocks uh
closer to the foreground
may actually be kind of dark on the
inside
and that the light tone we see may be
largely due to dust covering
uh and where the rocks stand up a bit
higher
and have less dust they tend to appear
dark so a lot of
you know new patterns are emerging um
and then of course one of the most
exciting and interesting things are
these
what we call the holy rocks uh that are
you know in some cases right under our
wheels and these smaller
cobbles that are right around the rover
um
i didn't mention uh but you know one of
the possibilities for those holes
is that they are what we would call
vesicles which would be
uh due to gas escape from a volcanic
rock
we're not calling them vehicles at this
point because we it's important for us
to stay open to the you know
different possible interpretations and
not get locked
yet on limited data but if they are
volcanic
that is is enormously important uh to us
because it potentially provides an
opportunity to get a
a really nice radiometric age or an
absolute date
uh if a sample like that comes back to
earth
um but then again if you go back to the
images from many
uh previous uh mars missions rovers and
otherwise
you'll see that that wind abrasion can
cause those
those sorts of holes in all different
types of rocks
so just a few of the thoughts that are
that are emerging and then of course
we're starting to get
views of the delta front now which just
have us you know on cloud nine
uh looking at some of the targets
further afield that we're excited to
explore
great thanks ken we have another phone
line question mark is astro from
astronomy magazine hi
thanks for taking my question um i guess
this is a question for al
and i was just wondering if you could
speak to
the performance of the landing vision
system if you've gotten a chance to dive
into that
how the range figure and terrain
relative navigation really
performed and just sort of what it was
thinking how it was making its decisions
as it descended uh and then when you
look at its performance and it's
accuracy
you know how do you judge it and can you
see that improvement over curiosity
yeah that'd be great i mean i was really
hoping for a chance to speak that a
little bit actually uh the
lander division system as part of the
train relative navigation system
really did great um in fact you know
here's some stats right the uh
uh based on the targeted well we took
many images on the way down uh we got
tons of landmarks where we're real very
able to match up what we saw with our
onboard map
was almost perfect better than many of
our field tests or even simulations
so we got a very good uh good lock on
where we were
and in fact when you combine that with
our safe target selection and where we
flew to
we only missed the targeted pixel by
about five meters
um so we were aiming for a particular
spot on the planet once it decided what
was reachable and what the safest spot
was
and given the given how well the lander
vision system performed
and our system in flying is there we
only missed by five meters
so that was really great i mean i think
the uh we've really showed that this
system can do what we
what we wanted it to do in helping us
figure out where to go and go to a safe
spot
great thanks al we have so many
questions coming in that we are going to
keep the phone lines open for a little
while longer remember
to press start one to get in our queue
for now i'm going to take a social media
question
from bob on twitter who asks how does
the processing power of the onboard
computer
compare to a great smartphone matt do
you want to
take that one yeah sure that's that's a
good question you know
in the space business we have to build
things that we know uh are gonna are
gonna work
and space is a pretty hostile
environment and the surface of mars is
even worse with the temperature swings
which we were talking about
you know you need systems that are
capable of
of dealing with the radiation and and
the temperatures
and and really perform with very high
reliability so as a result of that
we have a tendency to use systems that
have been around for a while the
well shaken out and on
on perseverance we're using the same
computer that we used on
on curiosity in large part because we
know it worked and we wanted to have
that successful flight heritage
that we had from from the previous
mission so this is a computer that uh
you know
you would have found 15 or maybe even 20
years ago
that were we're flying um having said
that
these edl cameras which we were just
talking about are
off the shelf you know state-of-the-art
new technology uh and uh
it is always a tool for us when we have
the opportunity
like we did in this particular
application uh to bring that kind of
technology
into our systems uh it's a very powerful
way
to multiply our our uh our functionality
and our capability and uh and so this
was a great example
of being able to use um new technology
uh so uh so i don't know if that's uh an
exact answer to the question
but uh in short that's uh you know
that's uh that's a summary great thank
you matt
and thomas uh we actually have a
question for you coming in
hayden an 11 year old from ireland on
twitter asks
what advice would you give to a budding
planetary scientist
in working towards maybe being part of
the mission that will bring
back samples to earth in the future
well i'm so glad for that question i
think about that a lot and the advice
would i would give is first of all
that's exactly the right time to get
into that career
braden that that now it could not be a
better time to
join that career or even if you started
10 years earlier
or you know in 10 years now is the time
to start that
the advice i would give is uh look uh
go really start playing with data right
away
you know i mean yes go to school you
know the teachers that are there are
your
allies going forward you know that
eventually
probably opened me perhaps at the
university or at an advanced school but
go to school do that but the other thing
i want to just
give you advice on hating this is you
know we're putting all these data out
be your own researcher learn how to do
that kind of
go play with it that's what research is
so much about and find
others who are just excited as excited
as you are
and i'm sure soon enough we'll have you
on our teams
in uh in the future that's some great
advice thank you thomas
and up next we have on the phone lines
alexandra witts from
nature magazine great thanks very much
i'm not quite sure who to address this
too but i wanted to ask about
insight and whether insight had heard
perseverance ending
so i'm not sure anybody up here has the
latest information
do you al have you heard anything new
heard from other folks on the team i'm
not sure this is official or not but
that they
haven't seen much yet i think we'd have
to check uh
to be honest to be sure we got the right
answer so
great thank you and then another phone
line question from
jackie goddard from the times of london
hello congratulations everyone one of
the most common questions that i get
from
readers who aren't generally a
scientific audience but
regular folks is what is the point
of spending all this money to go to
another planet and explore it
and sometimes that's not even a question
it's a statement there are cynics out
there
can you say why we explore and
how does humanity benefit from you
finding out what you find
out um and doing what you do thank you
give everyone who wants to answer time
to answer i can or thomas did you want
to
thomas yeah why don't i why don't i get
started
turn it over to you matt is that okay if
i start matt you're good with that
yeah yeah so frankly i'm thinking about
this question all the time
uh why do we explore and of course when
we do that at nasa i just want to just
let everybody know that if you look at
how much money we're spending on each
planet and the exploration of each
planet of course the majority
uh kind of that the money were the
planet we're spending most money on
of course is the earth the place where
we live where our friends live where our
history is
and we're so where our future is going
to be and so we're not confused about
the importance and
just just excited about the the uh
amazing future of what exploration is
uh going forward exploration for us
though is broader than just
what is useful right now and and the
reason we're so convinced that that is
important is first of all
the questions that have driven humanity
important questions truly historic
questions
in so many ways are what we're really
about addressing those and what we're
really about as humans we want to be
sure
you know as we look at our contributions
of our generations that we
really move forward uh what we know and
how also
uh really affect how we think about
ourselves and that
so often comes through our research
there's a second reason though
it's truly secondary but i'm going to
mention it anyway
so often and surprisingly
the results are the technologies that
we're building
for the very questions that are really
driven by
fundamental science questions are
extremely
useful and i just want to remind you
that perhaps today
whoever asked that question is driving
around in a car with a gps system built
for an entirely different purpose and
looked at the weather forecast
that they both have not anticipated when
in fact
we built the first earth satellite so
yes we want to
uh kind of focus on the immediate needs
today and it's really important but it's
so critical for us
as a species to look forward and explore
back to you thanks thomas i i think you
said it
really well you know i've been landing
things on mars now for
25 plus years and so i've had a chance
to go out and
and talk to a lot of different people
and it's it's not unusual
when somebody asks this question and and
i used to
you know have a long list of of reasons
uh
and there are a good long list of
reasons um but but fundamentally
i've come to the conclusion that in some
ways it's kind of a moot
question um because how can we not
explore
it's just who we are it's what we are
it's in our dna
you know you almost you couldn't stop us
as a species
from exploring i don't think i think
it's part of the reason why we're
you know at the top of the food chain is
because we're curious
because we want to go to places we
haven't been
we want to answer questions we don't
know the answer to
sometimes we want to find the questions
we don't even know need to be asked
you know it's just it's just part of
part of who we are
and uh and uh it opens new
horizons uh new frontiers it inspires us
um it inspires kids uh you know
and as as thomas mentioned all the
academic
programs that that are paying attention
here
uh science to technology uh
that that we bring to the table that
that's important for us
uh you know and uh i think that's the
best i can do to answer that question
um there's a lot of reasons
all right we can move on now to another
call from
matt kaplan from planetary radio
hi everyone congratulations uh from
not just me but all of the planetary
society um
i've been texting with uh our boss uh
bill nye the science guy who has been
watching
uh everything along with us and uh
here's part of his reaction
oh my this is astonishing astonishing
dare mighty things uh but here's my
question for ken wilford
uh ken getting these first images
and video from so much closer to the
surface
of mars than we have from the orbiters
in spite of the great job that they're
capable of does this
start to make you think about the
potential of
doing this on a regular basis from
balloons or let's say a helicopter
well sure you know almost everything i'm
thinking about right now
is potential um i've uh
i guess i've compared it um you know
several people
have asked me how i'm feeling you know
what take
and and closest thing i can compare it
to is i would say the birth of my
daughter
you know where uh the the cruise phase
that's about eight months long you know
is like at uh that nine month period
you're just waiting and you're just
hoping everything goes right and then
and then she's born uh in this case
we're on the surface
and it's real and the potential is
astounding i mean i was just
uh katie stack and i were just texting
last night as we got some new images
down and
and we're just you know we're so excited
like like kids just looking at every
picture and
and seeing so many new things and having
so many new ideas and new questions are
appearing
um and and the potential of it all is is
what strikes me
more than anything we have so far to go
so
so much to learn uh and i just couldn't
be more
more grateful uh to have made this
transition from
from all the years of hard work and and
stress and wondering
you know is it going to work out how's
it going to work out to now when
we actually get to do this thing uh it's
just
it's it's amazing
thanks ken and up next we have irene
klotz from
aviation week thanks
uh just looking ahead a bit um what's
been they put
it's probably for jessica um have you
made any progress
homing in on the site for the helicopter
flight demos
and um if so about how far from the
perseverance landing sites um are those
so the team has started to evaluate um
and is uh
using the images that we've received
from entry descent landing as well as
now these
uh images that we've acquired over the
last couple saws
uh we are fortunate to have landed in a
potential
um spot for that but the team is still
evaluating and uh is looking forward
to additional imaging from the 360
degree panorama from the
mass cam z as well as a
future data that's to come down so we
have not locked in a site yet and that
will still be
work for the team to go looking forward
whether it's here or a few 100 meters
away
and we have a social media question
coming in
jake who is 12 years old on youtube asks
was there one point you thought that
this would be impossible to do
that that's a that's a great question
jake um
there might have been many points where
it felt a little impossible
i'll just i'll give you my one moment
and then
the other folks may may want to add in
and that's uh
you know last march when the
uh pandemic struck you know we just
um we were we just shipped the
spacecraft down to kennedy
um dave gruel who believe it or not this
whole edl camera gig
is is is not what he does for a living
he was our assembly test and launch
operations manager
and he along with his deputy art
thompson were responsible for
assembling the flight spacecraft testing
it and getting it down
uh to the launch pad for for launch
that's actually
what he did for a day job so uh so the
pandemic struck about a year ago
and dave and i and art and others were
just constantly on the phone trying to
figure out how to react to it and how to
respond to it
you know we um i said it before we
didn't have a lot of margin we didn't
have a lot of time
um uh you know we were we were figuring
out a lot of things as quickly
as we could and our focus was shifted
from
trying to get the spacecraft built and
tested correctly and staying on schedule
for the launch
because if you miss it you got to wait
two years for these planetary launches
to mars
and suddenly our whole focus had to
change to keeping the people safe
and keeping their family safe as the
number one priority
and i wasn't sure honestly i wasn't sure
we could do that
i knew that if we couldn't keep them
just as safe as they would be at home
doing other things that you know that
that could be
that could be it for us for this uh for
this opportunity
we got tremendous support across the
board from the institution
uh here at jpl from headquarters thomas
and
and smd uh and we got through it
but um that was the existential moment
for me
uh that that very uh that
that time right there the first three to
six weeks
after after coat would really hit hard
so
anybody else same answer yeah exactly
same answers okay i'll add to that um
one of the things about that's
interesting about this this
these jobs we have are we spend years i
mean
seven or eight years for me and all
these guys we years and years
years of work building testing making
sure it's gonna work
and you know i say there's some kind of
stress um
involved when you spend seven years of
your career doing something and
then it all comes down to like one
moment and for me it's obviously like
those first images that come from the
cameras
like you really want that to work like
really really wanted to work and you've
tried
everything you could do to make sure to
work and so uh but you know
it it's definitely you know we all we
try to be open-minded about what could
go wrong
uh we try to cover cover all our bases
and um
and that's what's one of the great
things about jpl is that there's a
team of people here really smart people
uh you go to these reviews
uh to review your product your your
designs
um we call them withering reviews you
get you get a lot of tough questions
but that's one of the really you know
jpl is a real gem of a place because
we built this culture of always
questioning
um what could go wrong um but hoping for
the best and and
it's a really interesting experience i
think we all share that
i will agree i think we invite the
feedback from each other and our
reviewers
to make sure that we are thinking about
all the things that we need to think
about
and pushing ourselves to
meet those challenges and uh and of
course you want it all to work but
um you know there are some things that
you know
you worry that you didn't think about um
but as a community and as a collective
and as
you know a team you know we use each
other to help
make sure that we're covering those
bases
i mean the team really did persevere and
we are here today
up next is leo enright from irish
television
thanks very much raquel uh i i just
realized
there's no doubt about it 12 year olds
definitely ask
the best questions um but if you'll
forgive me
for um going geeky on this
uh could somebody talk to the
traversability of uh
canyon duchess now that you've seen
these amazing pictures
um do you think that you can just simply
turn around the rover and head directly
west northwest
possibly right past the descent stage
or realistically are you going to have
to go to the northeast
um around olympic uh and then
to uh chairman foyer i'm sorry for being
geeky but uh
it's kind of a serious question can you
move quickly so i can uh i'll comment
and all that can comment also
uh you know we have uh spent
you know as we do in our development
program as we were mentioning
a lot of time in different conditions to
evaluate the performance of our system
uh and one of the things that we did on
this mission compared to other missions
was to enhance that traversability
capability uh with enhanced autonomous
navigation
and as well as processing um while we're
driving so to increase our drive rates
now we have many more images
and still to assess um in terms of
evaluating
uh our path forward um but i will uh
i'll let ken speak to maybe some of the
areas that we are interested in pursuing
and what's really great is that we work
together you know with the science and
engineering team
to evaluate those paths and
what sort of terrain is the best
for our system
yeah so it's a great question and it's
it's our major focus right now on the
science team is
is answering exactly that question uh
what are we going to do what do we want
to do
uh where do we want to go and i'll say
first of all we're
so extraordinarily happy about exactly
where we've put down
because we ended up right on this major
geologic feature this contact we call it
between two um two differently mapped
units and so um you see there's this
sort of
uh undulating feature uh
that you know this sort of obvious line
um that we're we're landed right next to
and that's the big contact one of the
major features we were hoping to explore
in this mission and it it uh presents
for us uh one of the big mysteries uh i
mentioned the
you know the possible vesicles uh it
gets down to one of the big questions
for us early on
is what is that crater floor uh made of
and are there igneous rocks there
sedimentary rocks both uh
you know there's a lot of implications
for both so so
what i would say we're probably
currently leaning toward is is exploring
that contact which would not lead us
more
i think to the second um of the two
options but we'll see we we've got
a good amount of time while the team
does the commissioning and checks all
the systems out and during that time
we'll be
digesting all those new images and doing
a lot of strategic planning
evaluating different options um arguing
amongst ourselves
in the team right after this this uh
press conference is over our first
science team meeting
uh post landing starts immediately after
that so we'll
we'll start talking about just those
things so we'll see
thank you jessica and ken uh up next we
have
stephen gorman from reuters news
hi thank you very much can you hear me
okay yes we can yeah
so my question is i have like a question
about the superlatives regarding the
video footage of the edl sequence
and the audio of that gust of wind that
was picked up from the martian service
by the
by the microsoft so i believe is it
correct to say that this video
marks the first sort of moving footage
uh of a spacecraft from a spacecraft
from that speaker
uh showing it's it's it's uh descent and
landing on the surface of another world
you know mars or any world i think right
i don't see that
including the moon or an asteroid or
anything and then secondly is this
likewise is this the first chapel
recording ever made on mars
or any celestial object on earth or just
the first one that was made that's been
played back on earth i don't know if you
could
just uh clarify that
i can um let's see uh on your on your
first question
uh putting aside the apollo program and
the moon and just talking about planets
this is most certainly i'm pretty sure
as far as i know this is the first time
we're able to see ourselves
see our spacecraft land on another
planet
and uh and hopefully that that answers
uh the question that you you asked um
as far as sound um i'm sure anybody else
has any more
information but again as to the best of
my knowledge uh this is the first
planetary uh sound that's been recorded
uh so yeah go ahead justin
i can i can add to that uh in terms of
sound the the
um the insight lander has a seismometer
on it and they did measure
uh seismic signals that were
acoustically driven and then rendered
that as
as audio so that that could be
potentially another
another one but um in terms of like
imaging and doing video
um msl did have a descent imager that
did video
uh three and a half frames per second so
it was a little slower
that was the marty instrument um we've
also done time lapse of
deployments of things on the inside you
know we deployed a seismometer and we do
time lapse
video mars pathfinder we did time lapse
video of
the rover driving down onto the surface
uh but then again it was it's time lapse
you know so seconds in between frames
so it you know it's you you've probably
seen this they're all out on the
internet the the
rover movies um i worked on that as a
postdoc
actually but this is definitely the best
video
of any of them so i think we can at
least say that pretty definitively it's
it's just
it's a whole another level of
capabilities that we now have so
great well that is all the time we have
for questions today
thank you so much to our panelists we
unfortunately can't answer all the media
questions on there
for those with additional questions
please call jpl's
digital news and media office our social
media team
will continue to answer questions online
and we have a
reddit ama with perseverance team
members
starting at 1pm pacific time today
now to see the raw images of mars visit
mars.nasa.gov mars 2020
slash multimedia slash raw dash
images for more updates on the mission
visit nasa.gov perseverance